for decades the exact science of waifu's
has been a mystery as our collective
understanding of these entities and the
ways humans react to them continue to
baffle scientists to the modern day so
today I would like to present my
findings to you the board in hopes that
one day this research can be expanded on
and completed as far as we can tell wife
is a horrific Lovecraftian beings of
unknown origin with the power to destroy
entire species by inhibiting their
desire to breed while we have been able
to prevent this so far the human race as
time has gone on their attacks have only
become more effective and we get closer
to the possibility of mass extinction
every day the widely accepted root of
the word waifu stems from the butchered
japanese pronunciation of the English
word wife which has become the adopted
explanation by popular culture but
recent studies have suggested that the
word actually comes from an abbreviation
to the question waifu why am i forever
unloved as the entities themselves serve
as an answer to that question the exact
appeal of waifu stemmed from their power
to invoke a dormant gene present in all
humans known as the protec Jean once
invoked the protec gene raises strong
primal instincts in an individual
granting a sense of temporary euphoria
bypassing the develops logical brain
which would usually rationalize to an
individual their spending over $100 for
a JPEG printout on a bag of feathers
might actually be a bad idea even though
the effects of the protec gene is
normally seen in humans it should be
noted that animals also possess it with
the most recent case of its effects
being seen in penguins proven that even
animals are not immune to [ __ ] taste
while there is high variance among
individuals as to which waifu's most
appealing to them a peculiar event
occurs when enough anime fans gathered
together as a sort of hive mind begins
to form abandoning all the sense of
individuality in order to collectively
determine the most superior why fruit in
any given set this event is known as the
best girl automaton an event that causes
enough sodium chloride to form to poison
the surrounding area newcomers can often
be confused as to what exactly
constitutes the best girl but once an
individual spends enough time in the
community they may be able to develop an
additional sense a kind of sixth sense
in which on initial viewing of a new
show they can immediately detect who
will be best girl
phenomenon is known as the compounded
anime knurl character exposure response
though it's more commonly referred to by
a shortened form cancer while there's
yet to be any proven hypothesis around
what makes a best girl in any given
situation I would like to propose the
following theory that can break down the
overall effectiveness of any given waifu
in a best girl race the star with
personality this can be broken down into
two parts the depth determiner and
disposability the depth determiner
refers to the credibility of a certain
waifu and this is a slippery slope
why foods are meant to represent a
certain ideology within a life partner
and in this sense they can almost be
seen as something similar to deities in
fact some waifu's themselves are deities
because hey if an all-seeing all-knowing
omnipotent being exists that could take
any form why couldn't it be a cinder a
high school girl in short skirts or as
some experts in blood flow ology have
suggested why shouldn't it be assumed a
high school going short skirts however
it is important that they remain
believable but not too believable to
perfect and the entity may come off as
one-dimensional boring and flat but too
believable and it might become too
whoo-whoo-whoo human which brings us to
our second criteria disposability there
is an abundance of choice when it comes
to why free types but while different
personality types cater to different
individuals a large subsets may be filed
as a disposable why food in which a wife
we may just feel like a reskin version
of another character this is not to be
confused with trash wife use as now
refers to wife who's picked up by
individuals who are forsaken their
humanity at least a bit more so than the
usual anime fan the important thing is
that if a wife who can be easily swapped
out to any similar character from
elsewhere without much overall impact in
universe it increases their
disposability for example if you replace
Amara with a piece of turd wearing an
orange hoodie it would not actually make
much of a difference to the in-universe
narrative my apologies I would like to
make an amendment to that last statement
it would actually make a massive
difference the piece of turd wouldn't be
loud and annoying physical
characteristics are also a very
important part of any waifu as any
unique features may give them an
advantage to others without them this
includes but is not limited to fangs
versus thigh-highs alphas ponytails twin
tails real tails big boobs small boobs
no boobs and of course most powerful of
all a penis sex appeal is also an
important factor that is split into two
sections on one side you have waifu's
with high sex appeal that people very
much appreciate and find totally
acceptable to lewd and on the other side
you have the innocent kinds that have no
sex appeal whatsoever that people just
want to protect and everyone agrees that
under no circumstances are they
acceptable to lewd but people lewd them
anyway a wife who can increase their
best girl chances by appealing to a
certain fetish but the real power comes
when they allow an individual to
discover a fetish they never knew they
had
however sex appeal should never come at
the cost of going against the ideology
of being an ideal dedicated life partner
as this merely increases their thought
factor which is a death sentence for any
waifu
then we get to arguably the most
important factor for waifu's best girl
candidacy the kawaii coefficient this
refers to unique attributes a wife who
possesses which can be seen as cute with
a high-enough kawaii coefficient even
seemingly one-dimensional wife use can
have a high standing buddy arguably
should a common way to achieve this is
by giving them a weird quirk maybe they
really like explosions or licking people
or smelling people or their mentally
disabled or their a psychotic nutjob
mass murderer or their mentally disabled
psychotic nutjob mass murderer who's
also a lolly whatever it is it should be
noticed that pretty much any quirk can
be turned into something cute within the
laws of life ooh even if it makes
absolutely no sense in the real world if
she's overly aggressive and borderline
abusive we call that being sin delay if
she's a wise wolf god wandering the
world a human form we call that [ __ ] you
Dave this is not bestiality and if she's
a 500 year old immortal vampire who also
happens to be trapped in a lolly body we
call that I swear officer
she's totally legal the rules of the
real world do not apply to waifu's in
fact through the power of
anthropomorphism anything can be a waifu
anything cats
ships horses anything is fair game so
it's only really a matter of time before
we see anthropomorphize vacuum cleaners
ha way are you are you [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] kidding me of course this brings
us the most complex mechanic to
understand which is known as the y3 meta
the cutthroat game of best girl is a
constantly changing landscape with new
additions continually being added which
affect the overall ecosystem changing
the effectiveness of everything we
previously talked about an understanding
of this landscape rapidly improves the
wife who's standing in the current meta
I can increase or decrease their
viability for best girl in any given
situation for instance someone like
Amelia was quite strong and release
having pretty solid based that in every
category that made her a popular pick
but pretty soon after she just got
completely hard countered by Ram giving
her a loss by default where she hasn't
been able to recover ever since
something similar happened recently
between 0-2 and Ichigo from darling in
the Franks but that was more the result
of a high tier waifu being called out
for a 1v1 by someone who is clearly
still trying to climb out of bronze the
effects of the waifu meta are so severe
that there have been time periods when
nonsensical picks such as Dio Brando and
Kai ki have been viable for best girlf
even if science has never even
classified them as waifu's it is also
able to counteract the importance of
previously discussed factors
disposability is less of a factor if a
wife Lee is the first to popularize a
certain trend but a single imbalanced
wife who is also able to start the
revival of an old matter as we just saw
last year with Sagar II bringing the
resurgence of the Emoto meta we hadn't
seen since 2013 which absolutely nobody
wanted but we ended up appreciating
anyway even someone as old as Oscar can
remain relevant thanks to her constant
reworks if this is confusing for you
then I recommend sticking to the comfort
pics that have stood the test of time
and have remained viable in almost every
matter
for example someone like Rin will always
remain a strong pick as she's in the
Cinderella class which would pretty much
always be viable but this gives her very
high synergy with her twin tail and
thigh high builds Plus having one of the
best blush skills in anime when fully
maxed the only thing she has going
against her is when saber is counter
picked and even then it comes down to an
even skill matchup in conclusion the
size behind blye foods and their ability
to become best girls and complicated
field and science is still a ways away
from being able to find the ultimate
best girl while we can rationalize a lot
of the power through death determiner
disposability of thought factor and the
kawaii coefficients through the
power of the Wi-Fi meta and pretty much
anything being able to be turned into a
wife root whether it be through
anthropomorphize ation or just putting a
blush effect on something further
research is required but from what we
have discussed today I can conclude only
one thing for certain give an anime fan
any objects and they will find a way to
want to stick their dick in it
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month 2k must
live basil Patrick Madson Vincent Mooney
now Ken and everyone else in patreon for
helping support me for this month and
making this video possible
not too many updates today just
repeating the fact that I will be at MCM
London next weekend so if you're about
on the either of the Friday or Saturday
and see me walking around feel free to
come say hi keep an eye out on my
twitter at giga kz for any updates and
just in case i have enough time to sort
out a small meetup or something like
that anyway that's it from me
I've been gig ugh and I will see you all
next time